من جهتها قالت سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي انها قصفت برشقات
صاروخيه عسقلان وسديت ونير عام ومستوطنات
غلاف غزه الشمالي كما قالت سرايا القدس
انه وبعد عوده مقاتليها من مناطق الاشتباك
وسط قطاع غزه تمكنوا من تنفيذ سلسله من
المهام فقد قصفوا موقع كيسوفيم العسكري
والعين الثالثه برشقات صاروخيه وقصفوا
تجمعا لجنود العدو بقذائف الهون قرب بوابه
المدرسه شر خيم البريج واعلنت سرايا القدس
ايضا تمكن مقاتليها من استهداف اليه
عسكريه صهيونيه بقذيفه التندم شرق مخيم
المغازي وقصف تجمع لجنود العدو في محيط
موقع ابو صفيه العسكري بوابل من قذائف
الهاون اضافه الى قصف تجمع لجنود العدو
شرق قريه المصدر بعدد من قذائف
الهاون